It really puts things into perspective. I'm in the last chapter of my life.
And here we are camping in our backyard. You guys camp,
we've been camping on a beach too.
That wasn't a beach that wasn't a tent in our backyard. Oh, wait the beach. Yes.
We didn't go to the beach yet.
So I'll tell you it's something. All right.
I know what it's like to be alone, like on that show. Okay.
We tested his theory about George. Do you remember how you were like, Oh,
he's going to last two days. You are not wrong.
No. That's Oh God. You're so you're so beautiful. Um,
Mike [inaudible], um, alone. All right.
So when you're sleeping in a tent in your backyard,
and the reason why we did we have to do this is because, you know,
because of the flooding and the cat, we got a new, hard wooden floors and they,
they put this, um, really potent, um, shine on it or whatever, what's it called?
It was a coding, but then it wasn't the,
they didn't use the nontoxic one that I asked them to use.
And so they didn't give us any warning. And so when we came,
we knew we went upstairs. I was like, I told the guy, I was like,
is this safe to inhale? He was like, no, you should probably stay in a hotel.
And this was like at nine at night. And we were like, we have nowhere to go.
They didn't tell us.
And when you walked in the house, your eyes would burn. Right. For her.
It was terrible. All your animals.
Exactly. Put them away.
So then, um, we, we were, we got in a fight on my house.
We did kind of get in a fight. We did get into a fight. Yeah.
I like I'll sleep in the garage if you'd like out my mom's and you know,
it was a whole thing.
Here's the thing. He wanted to sleep in the garage with no windows.
And the smell was already empty going in through here. So I was like, Oh my God,
he's going to wake up dead. You know what I mean? Like,
I didn't think that this was not to me. This is not a, a good place.
Like there's no windows, no place for the, for the toxins to, you know,
the fumes to exit.
Anyway, um, she goes, we're gonna fight. And then she's like,
uh, I think she said let's camp back in the backyard.
Well, I said, let's go to my mom's because she has an extra room.
Yeah. I can't sleep in her mom's house. There's no way that's going to happen.
I just sit on the couch all day, all night. Um,
so we just pitched a tent in the backyard and we got all the dogs and stuff in
there.
Was me, Jules, Bobby, the three dogs inside the.
Tent.
How big is the Ted? It's a, it's a nice Mormon.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But it's an, a tent and that we're not no sleeping bags.
It was fun because we brought in the, we,
that's where we watched a Netflix documentary.
Korean pads.
We put these Korean sleep pads down there and then put some sheets on there.
And then it's like three in the morning and I'm laying in this tent.
Right. And it's like, they're asleep. I don't know how the. Right.
I got a dog on my face dog between my legs. Right.
And people are snoring and I'm just sitting there.
And then all of a sudden I realize that there's no Blinky.
I have no Blinky. You're gonna freeze to death. So I'm kind of getting cold too.
And I just knew, I made a decision in my mind. You're not sleeping in here.
You're. You're absolutely. So I just, I went,
I just laid there until the sun came up. He didn't sleep.
No, he didn't sleep at all. What was the fear.
Of sleep? And then I could see that the, that all of a sudden,
like as the sun rises, right. Then the tent becomes brighter. Yeah.
All of a sudden boom it's day. Right. And I'm still laying there.
You know what I mean? It was terrible.
But that had nothing to do with surviving in alone, in alone.
They're offering you money. Yeah. But it's also competitive. Right.
It's also televised. Those are three things that,
so me knowing that it's televised number two,
me knowing that it's competitive. Like if it's me against these guys. Yeah.
I have to show face. Right. And I was, so I would do it. I would last,
but there's nothing at stake,
so I'm not going to sleep and I'm going to sleep in there again.
Yeah. But it's so comfy.
Not for you. It's not comfy for me. Kayla, you stayed up the whole time.
The whole time I didn't sleep at all. And then what happened?
Did I fall asleep again during the day? Like for like 30 minutes during the day.
The little quick nap. Yeah. Yeah. But it's also like, it, it really wasn't,
it wasn't good conditions because this is over the weekend when we were in
triple digits. So we couldn't even sleep past, you know, 8:00 AM.
Digit. So then, um, but we've been, we were back in the rooms, you know,
at the house and it's like, um, yeah, camping is, you know, I dunno.
I dunno why people do it.
But you said that we would,
you said that we would go camping if you had your own tent.
Yeah. If I had my own Forman tent, I to sleep. Okay.
Is there a tent that has blackout shades?
That would be perfect. That'd be perfect for me there isn't. Yeah,
but what I would do is I would get like a Downy Downy, um, a sleeping bag,
right. The one with the little, you know what I mean, Bart and I would get,
I think that anything I'll be fine.
Yeah. Yeah. Well, let's try it then. Yeah. I have to go buy those things.
I'll buy it for you. Yeah. There you guys.
We're gonna take a really quick break to share this brand new juicy sponsor with
you.